mais d'abord donc d'abord l'essentiel du
discours d' emmanuel macron à strasbourg
avec nicolas fleury
une europe ambitieuse et indépendante
voilà les objectifs affichés par
emmanuel macron devant les
parlementaires pour débuter sa
présidence de l'union il se pose en
défenseur de l'état de droit une charge
assumée contre la pologne et la hongrie
nous serons au rendez-vous du combat
pour la démocratie libérale la fin de
l'état de droit
c'est le signe du retour aux régimes
autoritaires
au bégaiement de notre histoire emmanuel
macron vous affirmer les valeurs de
l'europe en renforçant sa charte des
droits fondamentaux
je souhaite que nous puissions
actualiser cette charte notamment pour
être plus explicite sur la protection de
l'environnement ou la reconnaissance du
droit à l'avortement
déclarations très symbolique juste
devant la nouvelle présidente du
parlement elle même opposé à libérer
mais soutenu par le groupe macro nist
une contradiction inacceptable pour
yannick jadot notre europe ne sera
jamais celle qui cède dans cette
enceinte même sur le droit à
l'avortement
ambiance électrique
quand l'écologiste fustige le bilan des
manuels macron sur le climat rejoint par
une partie de la gauche protégez-vous la
planète quand vous alliez à l'extrême
droite durban pour défendre le gaz et le
nucléaire voyez-vous là aussi il ne
suffit pas d'inscrire l'environnement
dans la charte des droits fondamentaux
autres moyens d'appui la puissance de
l'union emmanuel macron veut réformer
l'espace schengen écrit un nouvel ordre
de sécurité pour faire face à la russie
la sécurité de notre continent nécessite
un réarmement stratégique de notre
europe comme puissance de paix et
d'équilibré en particulier dans le
dialogue avec la russie un discours
salué par plusieurs présidents de groupe
à gauche comme à droite qui disent
attendre avant tout des actions
concrètes un président français devant
le parlement européen ça n'arrive pas si
souvent lent débat tout de suite avec
mes invités pascale joannin bon soir
dans ça vous êtes directrice générale de
la fondation robert schuman
sylvain kahn bonsoir vous êtes
professeur à sciences po bienvenue
bienvenue également guillaume klossa
bonsoir vous êtes le fondateur le
présent du think tank europanova avec
nous en duplex en visioconférence deux
autres invités sylvie brunet qui est
députée européenne modem vice-présidente
du groupe monier ou aux naissances
europe et puis franck louvrier le maire
l ère de la baule vous étiez le
conseiller en communication de nicolas
sarkozy bonsoir lors de la précédente la
dernière présidence française de l'union
européenne c'était en
évidemment matthieu croissandeau à mes
côtés et éditorialiste politique bonsoir
mathieu un soutien bienvenu à vous aussi
une question un peu général pour
commencer parce qu'elle joue à nice vous
avez pensé du discours du président
français
l'exercice est un peu formaté puisque
c'est le président français elle vient
comme tous les nouveaux chefs d'état et
de gouvernement du pays qui assure la
présidence du conseil devant le
parlement européen alors c'est une
police unique en vérité parce que le
président français de par la
constitution ne veut pas aller devant le
parle de voir avancer et nous sommes
aujourd'hui à public sénat il ne veut
pas y mettre les pieds et donc c'est un
exercice un petit peu obligé puisque le
conseil je rappelle pour nos auditeurs
et téléspectateurs
c'est un peu la chambre haute de
l'alléger 2
du pouvoir législatif et donc il est
venu devant la chambre basse et lui
parler par les citoyens pour expliquer
que pendant les six mois qui allait être
ou la lettre à la tête en effet de la
seconde chambre un petit peu les
priorités qui étaient les siennes avec
un certain nombre de dossiers qui sont
déjà dans les tuyaux qui va essayer de
faire avancer plus quelques initiatives
notamment sur la sécurité on attendait
peut-être ça de la france qui est un
grand un grand pays le seul état membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité depuis
que les britanniques sont partis dont il
y avait un peu inattendu sur ces
questions de défense on a envie que la
france prenne l'initiative et on se
souvient que la dernière fois donc en
2008 quand la france préside l'union sa
force à peu le respect de certains de
nos partenaires et on se souvient qu'en
2008 il y avait eu la taxe sur la
géorgie on peut se dire que là peut-être
s'il y avait quelque chose qui venait à
se passer en ukraine le fait que la
france préside le conseil pour monsieur
poutine serait aussi un signal peut être
plus fort que si c'était un autre état
membre plus petits en tout cas rennes
sylvain canet est ce que on n'y a pas un
effet loupe dans notre vision nous
observateurs experts journalistes
français sur ce qu'on attend d'une
présidence française abc saison c'est
choisir on se rappelle pas très bien de
ce café à la présidence portugaise on se
rappelle vaguement de ce qu'a fait la
présidence allemande parce que c'était
le vide et que tout le monde était au
taquet mais en général il ya que les
citoyens du pays qu'à la présidence
qu'ils ont vraiment au courant que c'est
la présidence donc vous avez tout à fait
raison mais cet effet loupe il se
retrouve dans chaque pays chaque
semestre différents voilà il ya quand
même une attente un peu plus importante
ce que disait pascal janin parce que
c'est la france la france siège
moi je suis assis bien sûr mais je suis
assez sensible aussi au fait que ya des
commandites ou voile on voit déjà se
dessiner certaines alliances c'est à
dire qu entre guillemets des fins d
alliance il ya des convergences un peu
classique ou un peu traditionnelle et là
on voit déjà comment emmanuel macron
s'est assuré de manière extrêmement
visible de l'appui de mario draghi sur
un ou deux dossiers qui lui paraissent
très important et dont il a parlé
aujourd'hui comme la réforme des
fameuses règles de convergence du traité
de maastricht d'ailleurs ils ont tout de
suite été rejoint par le premier
ministre espagnol
bon voilà donc j'ai oui vous avez raison
effectivement et pascale joannin aussi
dans la mesure où dans l'europe telle
qu'elle existe depuis une vingtaine
d'années depuis la naissance de l'euro
en tous les cas donc trente ans avec le
traité de maastricht il ya des espèces
de coalition un peu structurelles quoi
les pays du nord et du nord-ouest qu'on
a appelé les pays frugaux mais là qu'ils
sont en train de bouger à cause du coc
vidé à cause de la du danger si noir les
pays qui sont plutôt les pays du sud qui
en fait les pays du sud est pas parce qu
ils sont au sud c'est juste parce que
c'est des pays qui ont en commun d'avoir
des déficits budgétaire et un
endettement plus ou moins important
c'est moins le cas de l'italie mais
c'est le cas pour l'espagne avec un
endettement privé qui est très important
la france et la grèce qu'on a tellement
plu que très important donc voilà il ya
des espèces de deux grandes lignes de
structure mais c'est vrai qu'avec le coc
vide il ya des convergences nouvelles
qui ont lieu notamment sur le fait qu'il
faut se débarrasser des critères de
maastricht ce qui va très probablement
arriver là c'est provisoire jusqu'en
2023 mais ça va très probable c'est très
rare dans l'union européenne que le
provisoire ne devienne pas dû
définitivement fin là je parle sous
contrôle tout le monde ici mais il me
semble que c'est quasiment jamais arrivé
que quand on dit ça va durer seulement
deux ans au bout de deux ans on revient
c'est du courant tessa cette histoire
suivra évidemment guillaume klossa ça
revient que tous les 13 ans par les
initiants ce moment et on aurait pu
imaginer à 1 emmanuel macron peut-être
un peu plus emphatique ou grandiloquent
été assez sage en fait c'est vrai mais
j'étais conseiller spécial du ministre
en charge la présidence conseil de 2008
en fait c'est pas du tout le même format
parce qu'en 2008 nicolas sarkozy était
président du conseil européen et dans ce
cadre là il avait un vrai pouvoir sur
l'agenda sur l'agenda politique sur
l'agenda géopolitique et une capacité de
négociation puis on a eu les
institutions 10 watts qui fonctionne
plutôt pas mal mais dans ce cadre là
c'est le président du conseil européen
permanent charles michel est le
représentant pions se ce pouvoir et donc
il y avait une difficulté à être aussi
emphatique et avoir la même capacité
d'entraînement que nicolas sarkozy de
l'ambiguïté c'est que l'elysée jusqu'en
décembre à jouer sur cette ambiguïté en
faisant croire que c'était une
présidence de deux de même nature et ce
n'est pas le cas c'est pas le cas et moi
ce qui m'a frappé parce que le principal
du programme de la présidence française
de l'union européenne en fait on met un
coup de projecteur sur des dossiers qui
sont à l'agenda qui résulte d'un
consensus institutionnel qui a été
décidé en 2019 donc on parle de sujets
concrets et donc c'est juste la maturité
d'un certain nombre de dossiers qui sont
importants il se trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de ressentir la censure et
stimulant le faux passion des mânes
grangé créances française en revanche
emmanuel macron a lancé quelques idées
sur lequel il a absolument aucune
préparation et qui sont des idées plutôt
pour la présidentielle quand il parle de
revoir l'architecturé de sécurité et de
paix en europe je vois pas les travaux
qui ont été faits au niveau du conseil
ni même avec des institutions pour sas
et c'est une surprise est donc là dessus
il aura aucun impact parce que on ne
lance pas un débat comme ça sans l'avoir
vraiment préparé quand il dit on va
modifier la charte des droits
fondamentaux faut que c'est une très
bonne idée on s'est parlé
d'environnement est d'abord très bien
que c'est aussi un sujet pour la
présidentielle donc il a lui même de
manière assez fine introduit la
présidentielle est en fait la finalité
parce que donald tusk avait proposé
quand il est arrivé en 2017 emmanuel
macron de décaler la présidence de six
mois pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'une présidence française c'est quand
même important parce qu'il peut y avoir
de gros dossiers et qu'il faut que ces
gros dossiers soient traités dans la
sérénité la plus totale et qui ait pas
d'interférence avec le les débats
nationaux
et là on voit que c'est raté et donc
l'intérêt européen on est quand même été
de repousser comme les allemands
l'avaient fait en 2005 alors
effectivement la présidence française
elle s'est enfin la présidentielle s est
invité on l'a vu dans l'hémicycle on
retrouve marie brémaud qu'est notre
envoyé spécial à strasbourg face à elle
je le disais dans les titres on a
retrouvé beaucoup d'orateurs français
aussi en campagne d'une façon ou d'une
autre
oui on s'y attendait à la campagne
présidentielle française s'est invité
dans le parlement européen et ce sont
les députés français qui ont sonné la
charge à commencer par le candidat
écologiste yannick jadot il a utilisé la
quasi totalité de son temps de parole
pour instaurer un tête à tête frontale
avec le président français je cite
notamment vous présidez la france depuis
5 ans et à ce titre vous êtes comptable
d'un bilan d'autres ont suivi dans la
même tonalité très franco française
comme jordan bardella le président par
intérim du duer rennes ou encore la
députée européenne la france insoumise
manon aubry d'ailleurs son candidat jean
luc mélenchon était dans les tribunes
pour assister au spectacle même
l'allemand manfred weber qui est le
président du parti conservateur le ppe
lui il a appelé carrément à voter pour
la candidate valérie pécresse du grand
n'importe quoi qui a obligé la nouvelle
présidente du parlement la maltaise
roberta mais de cela à faire plusieurs
rappels au règlement appelant les
participants à à respecter le débat
l'europe et des institutions rappelant
aussi ici qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'un
débat national on a entendu un des gens
des eurodéputés crier stop au meeting
emmanuel macron lui il s'exprimait au
nom des 27 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens il a peu répondu
aux attaques nationale préférant
s'afficher comme au dessus des partis
mais cette confusion des gens et bien
élevé en quelque sorte un peu attribué
ou en partie puisqu'il a refusé de
reporter la présidence française de
l'union européenne pour qu'elle ne soit
pas concomitante à la campagne
présidentielle
marie brémaud envoyé spécial à
strasbourg mathieu vous avez écouté
évidemment avec attention le discours
des mamelles macron effectivement et ce
sentiment que les eurodéputés français
et peut-être lui aussi le président ont
transformé le parlement européen en
assemblée nationale en quelque sorte
c'est un festival de punchlines un
synthé qui prononcera le réquisitoire le
plus sévère et là un petit parfum de
l'est je bien descendu dans l'hémicycle
on a entendu un président de l'inaction
climatique pour le candidat à la
présidentielle écologie yannick jadot
10h de la france pour jordan birds est
là présent par intérim du rpt
rassemblement national président du
mépris pour la chef de file de la france
un soumise au parlement manon aubry
tient maintenant aubry justement qui
reprochaient emmanuel macron de voir
instrumentalisée cette présidence
française l'union européenne c'était le
9 décembre regarder ce tweet
instrumentalisation
de la présidence française macro ont
fait sa campagne
qui instrumentalisent quoi aujourd'hui
on se demande c'est un petit peu un
partout la balle au centre mais après
tout c'était de bonne guerre dira t'on
d'abord parce que et cette concomitance
entre la campagne présidentielle et la
présidence française l'occasion était
belle trop belle aussi parce que c'est
un moment assez inédit pour nous vous en
avez dit un mot pour nous français ce
que les institutions de la vème
république sont ainsi faite qu'elle ne
prévoit pas nulle part à aucun endroit
où le président puisse ainsi se faire
administrer ou même contester ou
apporter la contradiction par par ses
opposants
ça n'existe pas il n'a pas d'autres
comptent un nombre que dans les urnes en
france alors qu'ils qui a gagné à ce
petit jeu c'est là où ça devient
intéressant parce que prenait yannick
jadot par exemple s'est offert un peu de
lumière alors que il a bien du mal à
attirer les projecteurs dans sa campagne
présidentielle il a fait comme il l'a
dit les yeux dans les yeux avec un imac
rond mais son propos n'a pas été du goût
de tout le monde y compris chez ses
propres amis regardez par exemple ce
qu'on pense un de ses camarades
l'écologiste allemand reinhard bütikofer
qui dit voilà il ya une jadot parlant au
nom des verts et des écologistes au
parlement européen s'est saisie de cette
occasion pour prononcer un discours de
campagne présidentielle en tant que
candidat note mike peuvent-ils story
donc voilà ça résume bien quand un
jordan bardet lawman en ombrie ils sont
exposés à des revers de fond de court de
la part du président la république qui
s'est plutôt y faire écouter par exemple
la réponse d'emmanuel macro et jordan
barre des 20 vous avez quand même je
dois le salut est
très méthodiquement dit n'importe quoi
surtout les textes européens que nous
pouvions seigner et
je dois dire que l'esprit de méthode
avec lequel vous l'avez fait mérite une
forme de respect parce que il manifeste
une vraie cohérence de votre discours
mais ce n'est pas en disant
méthodiquement n'importe quoi même si le
n'importe quoi se tient qu on peut finir
à la fin par dire des vérités
oui mais voilà il a un peu d'expérience
même à caen il sait y faire je disais ça
rappelait je trouve cette ambiance où
une réponse soit de façon très technique
soit de façon très pédagogique soit de
façon très politique ces grands débats
qu'on avait eu évidemment à la sortie du
mouvement des gilet jaune vous souvenez
pas sommaire face aux élus face aux
français donc en gros match nul pour les
uns et les autres et une grande perdante
quand même l'europe comme toujours dans
les citoyens de connaîtront ce qu'ils
n'ont pas en tout cas écouter le
discours de maquereau a tellement les
enjeux les défis d'aujourd'hui alors je
vous rappelle qu'ici c'est pas la
campagne présidentielle française a fini
par toto n'est la présidente et nouvelle
présidente ultra conservatrice du
parlement européen roberta avec cela je
suis pas sûr que c'est convaincu grand
monde en tout cas on l'a pas vu cette
année sylvie on n'a pas encore entendu
nos invités en plaques sylvie brunet ce
que l'europe et la perdante de cette
journée
bonsoir
non pas du tout je ne considère pas du
tout que c'est la grande perdante j'ai
trouvé
le discours du président d'une grande
qualité d'un grand niveau il a vraiment
mis nous focus sur les points importants
la démocratie l'état de droit
le progrès la paix évidemment j'étais
assez heureuse de constater qu'on a
parlé d'europe sociale ce sont plus les
sujets c'est vrai que depuis des mois
voilà c'est mis en avant écoutez c'est
pas la grande perdante évidemment donc
pour nous en france ces fausses
écritures vous venez de le dire
parfaitement par le fait qu' on a les
présidentielles on s'y attendait pas de
surprise mais j'allais dire c'est pas
nouveau on a ça tout le temps depuis
depuis deux ans en fait il ya ceux qui
travaillent vraiment je pense un peu
pour le rend si travailler leurs
dossiers et on travaille bien ensemble
en plus dès qu'on sort de ces deux
politiques le travail avec tous nos
collègues en fait la plupart quels que
soient leur groupe politique en france
donc bon ça fausse un petit peu des
choses non je crois qu'il ya des idées
fortes qui sont vraiment sortis sur la
sécurité sur la défense une fois de plus
la nécessité d'une convergence sociale
avec des dossiers forts dont par exemple
la transparence des salaires pour
l'égalité des salaires entre les femmes
et les hommes
reste ce ne sont pas des petits dossiers
je pense que nos concitoyens ne s'en
rend pas compte il voit cette europe
très loin de ça mais moi je suis à
marseille c'est souvent encore plus loin
si j'ai du mal à leur expliquer cette
europe traitement pour eux au quotidien
pour les jeunes pour les apprentis pour
erasmus pour les femmes demain quand on
va réduire les écarts salariaux
mais moi je pense que c'est un bel
exercice aujourd'hui alors on a bien
entendu les arguments bel exercice du
président de la république et pourtant
franck louvrier est ce qu'il fallait
tiens par exemple pour éviter ce dont on
est en train de parler c'est à dire que
le calendrier présidentiel les enjeux de
la présidentielle qui font irruption au
parlement européen est ce qu'il fallait
décalé le calendrier
franck louvrier
bien sûr d'abord cette présence
française c'est une double erreur c'est
une erreur institutionnel est une erreur
politique une erreur institutionnels
parce que bien évidemment elle est
concomitante avec l'élection
présidentielle et comme vous le savez
comme l'a rappelé guillaume klossa en
plateau on aurait pu bien évidemment
faire un autre choix et c'est vrai que
du même coup sa saborde totalement la
présidence française comme la mettant
dans un climat politique dont on a vu le
triste spectacle cet après midi et puis
c'est aussi une erreur politique de la
part du président de la république parce
que bien évidemment il est là dans un
rôle qui va lui même m le perturber dans
sa campagne présidentielle qui devrait
annoncer dans quelques jours si ce n'est
quelques semaines et donc de cette là on
va avoir
résident bicéphale qui va me faire
peut-être que quatre mois de présidence
sur 6 n'ayant pas bien sûr la
possibilité politique et la puissance
politique pour pouvoir se déployer
pendant les mois à venir j'ai connu la
présidence comme vous le rappeliez de
nicolas sarkozy qui n'avaient rien à
voir en termes de tempo pour la simple
et bonne raison c'est qu'elle arrivait
juste après son élection présidentielle
et donc de ce fait là le présidentialise
est immédiatement dans l'action avec les
événements que l'on a connue à l'époque
donc voilà donc on est vraiment dans un
schéma complètement différent et c'est
vraiment regrettable ce choix parce que
c'est vrai que du même coup ça handicape
totalement cette présidence française
qui du fait en plus ce n'est plus la
présidence du conseil comme on l'a connu
il y a quelques années
vous pensez qu'il va y laisser de
l'énergie en quelque sorte c'est ça qui
pourrait qu'ils pourraient utiliser en
campagne présidentielle ici en france il
y laisse de l'énergie mais il est
surtout un sentiment de flou dans son
action parce que vous imaginez bien que
les français qui regardent la télévision
ce soir ne comprennent pas là où il est
il est bien sûr là bas mais il n'est pas
ici il est candidat sans être en france
tout en ne s'occupant pas des
préoccupations des français tout en
expliquant qui va s'occuper quand même
des français par exemple sur la sécurité
alors que ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
bien évidemment de la présidence donc
voilà tout ça fait que c'est une
perturbation supplémentaire qui est
vraiment inutile dans cette fin de
quinquennat qui termine pas très bien
mais quand même s'il incarne le
l'engagement européen
des mâles macron c'est un marqueur fort
de son parcours politique et c'était un
marqueur porte fort de sa campagne
présidentielle même il ya 50 ans qu'à
une forme de cohérence là et on peut
comprendre finalement qu'il est maintenu
ce que ce calendrier ah oui je suis sur
une tout autre analyse que celle qui
vient d'être fait je pense au contraire
que iliad et enfin c'est d'abord on veut
pas dire à la fois à bâle le président
de la république française comme les
autres premiers ministres lorsqu'ils ont
la présidence semestrielle en vérité il
m'écrit il ne maîtrise plus rien puisque
maintenant il ya un président permanent
du conseil européen et en même temps
dire ah c'est une erreur il aurait fallu
le mettre à un autre moment je dirais
pas que c'est parce qu'il faut être
cohérent à 30 ans et je termine bon
ensuite moi je trouve au contraire s'ils
voulaient que c'est très intéressant
c'est une coïncidence de calendrier bien
entendu on peut pas faire exprès mais
d'abord cette coïncidence de calendrier
bon je dire il ya des coïncidences tout
le temps quand on aurait pu demander un
report oui on aurait pu changer quand
jacques chirac a eu la présidence
française de l'ue en 2000 on était en
pleine cohabitation alors on aurait pu
dire mon dieu il faut surtout pas qu'ils
aient une présidence française pendant
une cohabitation ça va être un bordel
sans nom enfin bon je veux dire à chaque
fois on veut trouver des bonnes raisons
moi au contraire il me semble que une
présidence ou semestriels c'est
l'occasion dans un pays donné en
l'occurrence ici la france tout d'un
coup de faire énormément de pédagogie
sur l'europe et de mettre l'europe on va
dire de faire un zoom sur l'europe dans
débat politique comme vous le disiez
thomas eut en effet emmanuel macron se
singularise dans le paysage politique
français depuis cinq ans par le fait
qu'il est quasiment le seul candidat ou
le seul leader politique qui se repère
par son engagement européen faudra aimé
revoir qu'en 2017 il était le seul pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de
toutes les campagnes présidentielles de
l'élection au suffrage universel à la
vème république il n'y avait qu'un
candidat qui disait moi je pense que
l'europe est une solution et pas un
problème tous les autres y compris
benoît hamon y compris françois fillon
disait d'avoir l'europe est un problème
et de temps en temps une solution
aujourd'hui le seul qui dit que l'europe
est également une solution c'est yannick
jadot sauf que yannick gêne il fait même
pas 10% des intentions de vote donc en
clair moi il me semble que pour tous les
français qui se sentent qu'ils se
reconnaissent on va dire dans le fait
que l'europe et d'une solution avant
d'être un problème au moins les choses
sont claires il ya deux candidats dont
un qui fait moins de 10% des intentions
de vote 1 qui fait 25% des intentions de
vote tous les autres même valérie
pécresse mais michel barnier ont dit
vous vous rendez compte il faut revenir
sur la primauté du droit européen mais
on a halluciné quand on a vu des
candidats héritiers de nicolas sarkozy
de jacques chirac dire ça donc macron en
un sens il dit les choses au bon moment
où on voit là ça va être un marqueur de
la campagne présidentielle qu'il a
raison parce qu'elle voit l'un d'eux
finalement entre guillemets profiter de
cette présidence tournante de l'union
pour faire passer aussi je pense que les
ayants globice alors quelques messages
il doit pas voir en effet le problème
parce qu'en effet comme l'a dit sylvain
kahn s'était le plus engagé en europe
des candidats de 2017 et que donc pour
lui c'est tout naturel de faire campagne
sur l'europe et de peut-être essayer de
l'europe anisé le débat français où je
crains malheureusement que l'europe soit
aux abonnés absents ce alors qu'on a vu
que la plupart des questions sur lequel
les français ont des problèmes ça va
être une solution qui va être européenne
les vaccins à la santé on n'aurait rien
fait tout seul et c'est en effet une
solution européenne sur la migration va
rien faire tout seul on fera une
solution qui peut être qu'européenne
puisque tout est façon épatant sur la
relance à roland salle a été faite par
la france par l'allemagne puis par
l'union européenne c'est une solution
européenne et on peut dévoiler tous les
programmes donc croire que nous allons
avoir nous en france la solution divine
qu'on va imposer aux autres c'est c'est
vraiment se mettre le doigt dans l'oeil
et puis vous avez vu et vous avez mis en
avant tout à l'heure matthieu
croissandeau le problème des verts alors
les verts sont en effet aux parts au
parlement européen il ya quatre forces
politiques qui sont européenne il ya le
ppe qui n'est pas le parti conservateur
à sa partie ya un groupe conservateur 1
que dirige les polonais donc c'est parti
des chrétiens démocrates où il ya le ppe
donc il ya lille
il ya les social-démocrates par ordre
d'importance je les prends run yuki
parti libéral où il ya en effet les
maquereaux nist et des vrais libéraux et
puis le parti vert et puis j'avais
quatre autres partis qui sont des partis
anti européen et il se trouve qu'en
france nous avons des représentants des
partis anti européens qui sont malades
madame aubry pour la france a soumises
ou jordan bardella pour le freinage pour
le rassemblement national qui ont pris
la place des présidents de leur groupe
pour pouvoir en effet interposés le
président parce que sinon en effet
normalement ça n'aurait été ni yannick
jadot nimmano aubry ni ni jordan maria
qui auraient interrogé le présent
puisque au début c'était présents dans
l'air et vous avez vu aussi dans le
groupe des verts un certain nombre de
gens qui sont dit mais attend nous on
n'est peut-être pas dans la même famille
politique
emmanuel macron mais on est européen et
on n'a pas à critiquer le président en
exercice du conseil est donc l'allemand
ruttig but de bütikofer il a fait cette
réaction parce qu'en effet lui pensait
que on allait avoir un débat sur les
vrais enjeux climatiques qui sont portés
par tout pareil on va avoir une solution
européenne n'est pas national il vous la
trouvez qu en effet yannick jadot avait
fait plus de la politique politicienne
franco françaises cotées en europe et un
mois de mathieu puis ensuite guillaume
juste pour revenir sur les engagements
européens de débats les maquereaux c'est
vrai qu'ils aient même applaudir
d'europe en meeting ce qu'était moi
j'avais rarement vu ça à voir peut-être
françois bayrou temps et met clairement
où il est évidemment mais fort fourmont
faut remonter un petit peu plus loin
mais juste cette façon de distinguer les
européens contre les les anti européens
c'est aussi une façon pour lui de
redessiner le champ politique il a
explosé le clivage droite gauche et
c'est sa fameuse fameux refrain qu'on a
entendues qu'on aurait entendu
aujourd'hui sur l'arc progressistes face
à l'arc nationaliste les européens
ouverts progressistes face aux
nationalistes du du repli sur soi et
donc c'est pour ça qu'il y tient et sur
son discours c'est vrai que moi j'ai
trouvé assez consensuel ça casse pas
trois pattes à un canard ce sont sont
vrais discours sur l'europe il l'a
prononcée en septembre 2010 est à la
sorbonne il est là il ya elle est là la
pensée macro nien sur le rebord avec les
échecs qui a eu derrière à ceyrat des
réactions le fait que c'est pas si
simple qu'il fallait qu'on va régler
il y avait quand même là une occasion tu
vois de loyer d'un discours
est ce que le président c'est une
question que je pose pas du tout
spécialiste comme vous est-ce que c'est
pas quelqu'un qui se révèle en fait dans
les actes ses adhérents situation s'il
se passe quelque chose c'est là où on
voit si un président peut mettre sa
patte ou pas réellement français de
l'union président de l'union de l'union
européenne est ce qu'on voit ce que
c'est en temps de crise que ça se révèle
c'est la mairie c'est le président ou
est ce qu'on peut vraiment imprimé un
agenda partie de la vie c'est qu'il est
il est même pas président du conseil de
douilles l'européenne une présidence qui
il est président du conseil président en
2008 voilà tu laisses moi finir au pire
ça retombe pas dans un débat ce qu'il
n'ya pas de président il ya une
présidence qui est exercée par un pays
plus exactement par un gouvernement et
le rôle malheureusement du président du
conseil c'est plutôt un rôle de près de
d'empereur à la japonaise inaugure les
chrysanthèmes
donc il ya pas deux il peut
ce que si tu dis ça nos amis qui sont
passés avant non ils ont une
responsabilité d'avancer
et s'il ne l'est pas pas mentionné le
relève des sabots salle des cistes
européen mais c'est la responsabilité de
faire avancer c'est pour ça qu'il faut
un contexte pour faire avancer et c'est
pour ça que gerhard schröder en campagne
avait décidé de différer sa campagne et
donc sa 500 chose d'important
deuxièmement sur le discours de la
sorbonne 2017 le contenu du discours à
80% c'est
le programme de la commission européenne
qu'il avait préparé post break site est
un programme convergent des quatre
groupes au parlement européen et donc il
a récupéré le problème de l'effet
d'entraînement de ce discours c'est
qu'il n'a pas crédité notamment les
personnalités plus avancé de ceux des
différents groupes et on a perdu trois
ans et la vérité elle est là c'est que
si on est européen on n'est pas
seulement dans le discours on l'est
aussi dans la méthode est ce qu'on lui
reproche et même les boutiques aux
fleurs que je connais les autres disent
mais il ya un problème de méthode
on aurait tous préféré qu'il le fasse
après et qu'il le fasse avec plus
d'énergie parce que les dossiers sont
extrêmement importants en ce moment et
on a besoin de l'énergie française et la
vérité c'est que le gouvernement doit se
mobiliser et qu'on est que les
présidentielles doivent être bien
effectué requiert une action
gouvernementale qui n'est pas compatible
avec une campagne présidence alors je
dois entendre là dessus la réponse de
sylvie brunet ce qu'il ya déjà une
déception des députés européens de cette
présidence française tournante de
l'union
je ne vous dirai pas du tout je veux
dire qu il n est pas du tout parce que
une fois de plus près on discute quand
même on a la chance avec des collègues
qui viennent de 26 ans aux pays
non pas du tout ce retour je vous
rappelle quand même que depuis deux ans
on a une certaine crise pandémique
mondiale ce n'est pas rien en juillet
2020 nous n'aurions pas eu lax emmanuel
macron angela merkel le parlement la
commission on n'avait pas ce plan de
relance exceptionnel avec pour la
première fois dans des plans qui est
fait par la commission directement des
subventions aux pays les plus touchés
mais c'est inédit on oublie tous comme
si haut il n'y avait rien qui change et
on est dans un mais on est dans un monde
qui bouge donc il ya eu cette capacité
d'adaptation et au contraire nous sommes
très attendus sur un certain nombre de
sujets le numérique digital services à
digital marque à 9 bien sûr le social
que la dilution ur d'un j'en sais
quelque chose et là au contraire les
députés et européens d autres compris
d'ailleurs nos collègues français ça va
être bien avec nous attend beaucoup de
la france pour pousser des axes est
d'ailleurs aussi des actions sans doute
plus forte sur la jeunesse qui souffre
particulièrement depuis deux ans donc
c'est pas comme quelque chose là il ya
six mois et puis il se passe plus rien
après de la part de la france il s'est
rien passé avant vous parlez du portugal
il ya eu le sommet de porto de sommet
social où emmanuel macron a été un des
seuls dirigeants à y aller apporter les
sujets sociaux moi j'étais rapporteur
sur les travailleurs des plateformes
numériques nous portons tous ces sujets
pour créer de nouveaux droits pour ces
personnes il est des présents donc c'est
pas c'est c'est logique voilà 17
continuité pour moi allez je propose un
élément dans notre débat une réaction
celle de clément bonne ses secrétaires
d'état évidemment chargé des affaires
européennes intel vous pourrez retrouver
en intégralité
samedi à 16h30 dans ici l'europe
nouvelle mission sur public sénat on
écoute clément en bonis défend l'idée
d'une europe qui protège des avancées
concrètes sur l'ambition climatique la
taxe carbone aux frontières je crois que
ça réuni beaucoup de sensibilité
politique ce serait une avancée d'avoir
un accord j'espère aller plus loin
possible à l'accord politique pour ce
semestre d'avoir un accord final une
législation en place sur la question de
la régulation des grandes plateformes et
puis sur le social sur l'europe sociale
s'est longtemps été un slogan il faut le
dire il ya eu des avancées ces dernières
années sur la réforme du travail des
tâches et la lutte contre la fraude à ce
travail détachés et ont peu à voir avec
la directive sur les séries minium et
oui avec la protection des travailleurs
des plateformes y aura des débats
techniques mais je crois qu'on partage
cette ambition de redonner quelques mois
ce sont les droits sociaux c'est très
important après la crise c'est tous ceux
qui travaillent sur nos vélos dans nos
villes avec des conditions difficiles
c'est l'europe qui peut apporter cette
protection l'europe qui protège franck
louvrier je reviens vers vous comment
votre candidate comment valérie pécresse
peut se différencier des manuels macron
sur l'europe sur cet engagement européen
en apportant des solutions d'abord
franco française et ensuite des
solutions européennes vous savez tout à
l'heure on expliquait que vis-à-vis de
nos 26 c'était formidable je pense que
le le visage que a donné la france
aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis des autres pays membres a été
plutôt catastrophique dans un débat
franco français qui ne regardaient qui
était très nombriliste et on peut pas
considérer que c'était satisfaisant et
que quand vous est à 80 jours du premier
tour des élections présidentielles vous
croyez que les français ils attendent
une solution de l'europe alors que ça
fait cinq ans que manet le maquereau et
aux responsabilités mais vraiment faux
faut être complètement déconnecté de la
réalité pour expliquer que les solutions
vont venir maintenant que l'europe dans
les 90 jours qui restent franchement la
candidate valérie pécresse elle va
chercher à apporter des réponses qui
vont être des réponses concrètes comme
elle l'a fait hier soir sur une chaîne
de télévision aux préoccupations des
français elle va pas quand même
considérer que ça doit être dans l'ordre
du jour des réunions européennes des
jours à venir ce serait vraiment se
moquer des français et vous voyez je
pense que là c'est aussi ça peut
peut-être des faits le désastre de
l'image de leur enclos vous dire c'est
comme d'habitude on parle pratiquement
jamais d'europe dans les campagnes
présidentielles françaises mais vous
croyez que c'est maintenant qu'on va le
faire vous savez nicolas sarkozy quand
il était candidat à l'élection
présidentielle ça a été le seul candidat
à faire une conférence de presse avec la
presse étrangère à l'époque tout le
monde le regarde est un petit peu de
loin en lui disant mais qu'est ce qu'il
fait c'est pas eh bien justement c'est
porter les sujets à la hauteur bien sûr
des dimension européenne et
internationale
mais y apporter des réponses franco
française parce que la preuve c'est que
vous le voyez bien tout ce qu'ils sont
en train de détruire l'europe et je
pense notamment à eric zemmour qu'est ce
qu'il a fait il est allé bien évidemment
sur le sujet de l'immigration en
parallèle aujourd'hui pour montrer qu'il
y avait pas de réponse donc attention on
joue trop avec l'europe dans des
périodes trop politicienne ce qui fait
qu'on abîme l'europe et je crains que la
décision qui a été prise vraiment de
confondre le calendrier politique avec
calendrier européen est une erreur
majeure pour l'europe et pour vous
parler et envoyer des images du discours
de nicolas sarkozy devant le parlement
européen c'est le 10 juillet 2008 vous
vouliez intervenir moi je suis un peu
étonné de ce que ni franck louvrier
parce que l méthode mêle et eric ress
soit élue présidente mme 9
24 avril elle va prendre la présidence
française pour le restant de la du
mandat et donc elle savait obligé de
reprendre les dossiers qui sont en cours
qui sont pas que des dossiers français
mais qui sont des dossiers que nous
portons etc
continuent tout de même je rappelle
quand même que c'est tous les textes que
nous examinons ça vient de la commission
met donc on en était là difficile
compréhension que les représentants du
gouvernement sont les législateurs au
niveau européen donc il ya bien en effet
une vision peut-être franco française il
faudrait surtout avoir une vision franco
européenne parce que de toutes les
façons on peut porter des arguments
français en europe y ait une solution
européenne et on a nos partenaires qui
nous disent oui mais vous faites quoi
parce que la migration ça va pas se
résoudre parce que madame pécresse aura
une idée que ce sera l'idée qui sera
forcément adopté hawaï et au conseil
européen dans les 80 jours qui restent
voilà
donc il faut faire attention à ce qu'on
dit parce que il ya la france dans
l'europe et donc rogner depuis le début
en plus ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui on
est assez schumann et on ne rien d'une
1950 ça marche plutôt bien tous les
présents la république qui ont été élus
sont tous étaient président européen de
coeur ou de réseaux en a aucun qui a
renversé la table en disant je veux pas
de votre europe voilà où on essaie de
faire avancer les dossiers et on sait
qu'on est 26 et que si on est là où on
est c'est parce qu'on est tous ensemble
parce que sinon on serait pas grand
chose franck louvrier un mode réponse
est ensuivi oncle ça non mais à la fois
bien sûr que le discours il doit être
dans la perspective européenne mais je
vous rappelle qu'on est en élection
française et que les français ils
veulent des réponses immédiates sinon
c'est la voie vers les extrêmes je
voulais sur vous faut vraiment ne pas
penser aujourd'hui que on va leur dire
que la réponse va venir maintenant de
l'europe c'est plus possible ça fait
cinq ans qu'ils gouvernent donc bien sûr
que les réponses doivent être dans la
logique international une logique
européenne mais elle doit être franco
française c'est ce qu'ils attendent les
français ils attendent ça ils
n'attendent pas qu'on remette le bébé
avec l'eau du bain au niveau de l'europe
guillaume klossa c'est moi je vous
entends je me dis une occasion un peu
manqué de feu de fer dont nous on en
fait sur ce plateau on se dit dégoûté
c'est de la pédagogie sur une présidence
française de l'union ça pourrait être
l'occasion de la presse publique enfin
en ce moment il faut voir la couverture
aujourd'hui du discours de mails mâcon
tous les jours nous oui mais les
campagnes françaises ce qu'avait dit pas
vous mais moi je voyais ça je ne pense
pas qu'on fasse de la pédagogie parce
que c'est pas audible du côté du citoyen
gg mais ce n'est pas audible parce que
ces deux prix dans la cacophonie de la
présidentielle et il ya tellement de
signaux contradictoires et les
journalistes n'en sont pas tant que ça
il n'y a pas tant des missions de
décryptage où on a le temps d'en parler
les gemmois de verizon
mais c'est que ce n'est pas audible pour
moi c'est ce existe pas ou en tout cas
moi je suis plus optimiste mais je pense
moi je suis assez optimiste sur le sujet
europe et en france je suis convaincu
que de façon je sois emmanuel macron ou
valérie pécresse si elle lui succède
la présidence française aura une
continuité il ya une machine
administrative et
j'espère qu'il y aura une continuité il
ya une machine administrative de grande
qualité et toi emmanuel macron que
valérie pécresse savent que c'est qu'une
présidence française puisqu'elle a elle
même piloter des réunions ministérielles
lors de la dernière présidence donc ça
si moi j'ai pas j'ai pas de doutes sur
la continuité d'état j'ai juste un sur
sa chance que c'est que la machinerie
d'une présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne pour l'avoir gérer c'est que
je vois bien que ça demande une énergie
folle et que si on veut réussir il faut
se concentrer et il ya énormément de
dossiers extrêmement importants qui sont
sur la table qui viennent pas d'
emmanuel macron disent que c'est
l'accord du conseil européen de juin
2019 on s'est mis d'accord sur une
feuille de route il trouve que ces
sujets arrivent à maturité maintenant et
pour les six mois qui vont suivre et
donc les discussions et les négociations
on apprenait à mi mandat des
institutions européennes c'est
maintenant généralement qui a les
accords donc on est dans la période
critique les 12 mois qui viennent c'est
tout et cette période requiert un
maximum d'énergie et un maximum de
sérénité
construit par de toute façon maintenant
c'est comme ça donc
on m'attend c'est comme ça on y est donc
espérons que ça se passera pas aussi mal
que guillaume klossa l'honore je ne sais
qui
les accordent des prêts par ailleurs si
par ailleurs moi je suis quand même
frappé par le fait qu' ici bien parce
qu'on est en campagne électorale pour la
présidentielle on a eu ces quatre
derniers jours deux discours de marine
le pen qui a fait état de sa appelons ça
de sa doctrine sur l'europe on a eu la
même chose de la part de mélenchon bon
voit que jany jadot a trouvé une
occasion de faire état de sa vision de
l'europe dans le cadre du débat qu'on a
dont on parle aujourd'hui
voilà on attend la doctrine européenne
de madame taubira hidalgo voilà donc un
bon même si ça me met un peu de foot
voir on va dire en soit dans l'énergie
que peuvent consacrer les ministres
français à la présidence soit s'il ya eu
une comme dire une percussion avec la
campagne électorale moi je trouve ça
formidable que à l'occasion de sa
présidence française tous les grands
leaders français qui sont candidats même
eric zemmour dont on savait pas qu'ils
connaissent et quoi que ce soit à
l'europe a fait aujourd'hui un grand
discours soit disant sur l'europe voilà
bah l'europe a jamais été autant au
coeur du débat de la campagne électorale
que pendant qu'une présidence française
alors un élément qui va dans votre sens
et pédagogie la conférence de presse de
marine le pen c'était hier sur l'europe
notamment elle a mis l'accent sur la
souveraineté nationale pour défendre
l'idée de souveraineté européenne comme
le font les jumeaux les jumeaux macron
pécresse me paraît en outre totalement
incompatible avec la fonction
présidentielle
gravé dans le marbre de notre
constitution qui fait du président de la
république le garant de l'indépendance
nationale
ce que je souhaite c'est inclure dans le
référendum une modification
constitutionnelle
qui dirait la chose suivante qui me
paraît d'ailleurs le seul moyen de faire
respecter la souveraineté d'un pays qui
est de dire tout texte européen qui va à
l'encontre de la constitution française
restera inapplicable en droit français
tout texte européen qui va à l'encontre
de la constitution française restera une
applicable en droit français pascal
loana elle s'inscrit marine le pen dans
la dans la ligne de ses amis polonais ou
hongrois elle est en effet dans une
ligne qui est fidèle à elle même mais
bon moi je moi je me suis en 2017 marine
le pen 2 2 aux débats du deuxième tour
perdant
visiblement l'élection sur la question
de l'euro et quand vous l'entendez
aujourd'hui sur cette question là elle a
changé radicalement de 2,2 de 2,2 de
deux discours puisqu'elle est plus
contre l'euro et elle n'est plus contre
les rôles l'union européenne en tant que
telle elle veut dire que c'est simple
bon alors donc bon elle est là elle est
elle a beaucoup dit tout et c'est
n'importe quoi dans ces dernières années
sur l'europe essayons de faire en sorte
que l puissent pouvoir se qualifier au
deuxième tour et elle sait que si elle
est anti europe vraiment primaire les
français
sont plutôt comme tous les citoyens de
l'union européenne y compris les
polonais et y compris les hongrois
majoritairement pour l'europe donc il
faut faire attention aux dirigeants les
dirigeants nationaux il faut qu'il fasse
attention parce que les populations
elles savent ce que l'europe a apporté
elle espère beaucoup de l'europe donc si
on a un discours trop franco-français
est passé européen ils vont sanctionner
parce que ils savent très bien que la
plupart des solutions elles ne sont pas
que franco française et les citoyens
attendent que à côté d'eux d'une
discours français on a un discours un
peu plus européen parce qu'on sait que
la plupart des solutions elles ne seront
pas seulement national puisque tout ce
qui est aujourd'hui dans le débat on se
dit mais où est l'europe et l'europe
elle est là parce que les chefs d'état
et gouvernement veulent bien que ce soit
européen et quand ça ne l'est pas et on
voit que ça patine oui je suis pas sûr
que les électeurs de marine le pen ou
d'eric zemmour peut-être même deux jean
luc mélenchon soit effectivement sur la
ligne que vous décriez accueilli jean
luc mélenchon ni marine le pen ne
propose plus aujourd'hui de se vêtir de
l'ue ont bien géré
après sortie donc je mettrais un bémol à
ce que vous dites si oui on parle
beaucoup de l'autre mais on en parle
beaucoup en mal dans sa campagne
présidentielle c'est quand même le bouc
émissaire pour une habitude en france
fin mai comme d'habitude
milliards juste omis
conclusion on a entendu des choses chez
les républicains pendant notamment la
primaire y sont là plus sur la prime aux
îles compris de la part de michel
barnier juin
dix ans zéro mais un avantage comparatif
c'est à dire que là au moins sur
l'europe encore une fois si on met à
part yannick jadot qui ne décolle pas
dans les intentions de vote il est tout
seul ça veut dire que du coup parce que
dans l'histoire de france et là c'est
pas seulement un cinquième site y
compris la quatrième république d'accord
il se trouve que tous les grands partis
disons-le à ce qu'on appelle
classiquement la droite de gouvernement
et la gauche de gouvernement se
caractérise en france en particulier
c'est un cas un peu dans tous les pays
européens mais surtout en france par le
fait que ces grandes familles politiques
sont depuis 1950 divisés sur la question
européenne je vais pas rappeler ici que
l'échec de la csd a quand même été
causée par lé indiscipline de la moitié
du groupe et ses filles aux socialistes
donc de l'époque donc en fait en fait
qu'est ce que fait macron macron il
envoie un énorme signalent à tous les
électeurs ont en tout cas tous les
français qui peuvent se reconnaître soit
sheller soit chez ps taubira et c'est en
leur disant si pour vous l'europe est
vraiment le critère déterminant ou un
des trois critères déterminants et bien
avec moi il n'y a aucune ambiguïté vous
savez que en votant pour moi vous
montrez vraiment pour un européen
convaincu et vous ne serez pas déçus on
peut pas dire ça matthieu croissandeau
le rappelait mido pécresse on ne pouvait
pas lire de chillon comme on ne pouvait
pas d'ailleurs le dire du shirak de 1980
a rappelé vous l'appel de cochin bon
voilà donc de ce point de vue là en tous
les cas on peut dire que macron
instrumentalise la présidence française
oui mais il le fait encore une fois pour
des raisons qui me paraissent
pédagogiquement dernier moins
intéressant rapidement classé la fin des
débats pour rayon ton sens ma vécu
si on regarde tous les grands pays
européens je pense à l'espagne à
l'italie récemment en allemagne ce sont
des partis pro-européens les grandes
familles politiques sont des partis pro
européens sur la situation française je
pense qu en effet celui qui gagnera aura
une empreinte européenne je suis plus
réservé sur sur pécresse parce que je
trouve qu'elle a été la plus prudente
dans le lait non mais de loin la plus
prudente dans les débats internes et
secundo on n'a pas encore entendu sur sa
vision européenne donc laissons lui la
chance de s'exprimer la vallée crazy que
j'ai coincé elle est peut-être quoi ça
mais c'est elle d'avoir le talent le
sortir de cette ornière hisser en france
quand même négocié la démocratisation
d'erasmus et l'inscription des apprentis
elle n'avait pas eric ciotti
merci à tous d'avoir participé c'était
passionnant ici et en duplex évidemment